hello everybody welcome back to this
play in this story all right
I grew some balls so let's go in here oh
that didn't do jack diddly
Oh seems to be blocked from the other
side well isn't that fantastic
this didn't do anything
I even put them there what my father
study is locked I need to find another
way yeah yeah I need to find another way
locked but I can finally hear breathing
sounds on the other side no you cannot
no no you cannot you cannot hear that
that is a lie that is a dirty dirty lie
that's a lie
that is such a lie that is so much lie
so much lie no no no oh no no no because
the back of my mind is telling me to
leave that open just in case something
is good above wouldn't know but we did
open see what happens oh it's nice and
bright in here
oh that's so nice ah so nice oh I'm a
fool to myself but I know what you all
want to see is this a piano that someone
was playing oh I say huh fish ha ha
ah hi why you be do that oh no oh no
turn oh no 23 December 1843 Anna my
dolly
I'm so sorry things turned out the way
they did and even more than that and
forever sorry I never had a chance to
explain everything to you explain why
disappeared it was just never enough
time not enough time for my work my
friends
but most importantly my family and now
look where my work has gotten me if
you're reading this then I am already
gone I had hoped you would get up the
courage to enter this room my private
study and eventually come across the
snow but if that is the case then
perhaps the day I have feared to come
has already happened if that object ever
found I found ever gets into the wrong
hands
the whole world as we know it could
change forever the whole world as we
know it could ever there's so much more
I need to tell you but of course not
enough time my lab and secret room you
know the one downstairs through the wine
cellar I admit there may be things
you're regrets regrets seeing down there
but it must be done Emma I'm not sure
what the best course of action is I have
heard many great perils and storing such
an orb yet I can already feel the
changes taking place soon I will no
longer exist so I write this with haste
I still can in any event you must
retrieve that orbit keep it somewhere
safe where it cannot possibly get into
the wrong hands there's an item in the
dining room and you'll need in order to
get to the wine cellar please be careful
and the god-knows-what I awoke under
this estate when I found that object do
take care of Neal
he's a good man for you and be careful
love you father Robert you're doing so
good tough you Father you love your
father Robert well that's not good
[Music]
I wear little chairs cover up my clothes
my eyes where did those series come
where do they hang
I left my lantern on that shouldn't have
scared me with a [ __ ] I didn't know it
was a buffer but then who says that you
in the closet
oh boy I gotta get in the closet I know
I know I know I know I know I know I got
a second ha ha in the closet OOP you
didn't hear a thing
douche Linda bring do it yeah good the
fingers good we're gonna blocked it up I
mean I should have locked up the door oh
there he is go away go away go away go
away are you gone
are you gone are you gone are you gone
hey what the hell
[Music]
maybe busted down the wrong door it's
like a red glow coming from I guessing
that room over there I gotta go in there
once he's gone
[Music]
oh hey oh oh you're gonna bust down that
door
for me that was the busted door he was
busting down ah okay all right oh man I
don't know how but this discussive story
is getting to me this customer story has
got me like a couple times down we just
started okay I was in here anything this
match barrel some boxes aha tinderbox
owns it that's it that's it that's it
that's it is that it looks like it some
writing on the floor under seen that
before yeah I've never seen these
symbols before I don't think anywhere in
these games huh this is not a full
conversion table this is just a normal
this is just a custom story through the
portal was a full conversion mod this is
dumb wow this isn't normal and ordinary
but it's very good the doors are sealed
shut you know what I want to know what I
was wondering while I was reading the
note from Emma's dad he's why Emma was
still living in this place why all of a
sudden did where are the servants
obviously this is a mansion so the
servants might I don't like that already
ah come on come on
all right down tail with dad please go
do Pat it I'm breaking all the rules I'm
home alone yeah dong oh no oh no don't
do it again
nothing okay
I hate closets so much now bones I like
tight they got a female voice for the
guests and stuff that's cool
pick up crowbar picked up tinderbox turn
off what the hell this is a guy like
spread-eagle in their ego it burns
okay dad you oh yeah the initials G ah
God yeah so I'm gonna happen in here
hi no kidding
no joke oh man is standing there in the
doorway well what am I gonna do now
you're half car nerd me I see you in
there I think I hate about these getting
in closets for you guys you can't see ah
I'm great my sanity is gaining come home
I could take her I got like the muscles
of an Olympian well you know I was even
fine was the grunts before yeah he looks
bad in that red light
okay yeah go away go away friend oh no
need you around here no one needs you
around here
oh he's still there
okay is he leaving I think he's leaving
just pray right soon and then we can
move on with our lives
what oh yeah there he goes okay huh all
right good
I was thinking that they were gonna do
another mannequin thing but it's kind of
intelligent because I would have I peed
my pants and they can't over use the
same thing over and over it's all about
pacing you took oh this is where the
muscles coming half expecting something
to happen music changed
oh no level change I was hesitant about
entering that wine cellar hesitant about
everything that happened that day but I
gritted my teeth and descended the long
dark scarecase into the unknown
I like these type oh they look I know
that you guys have trouble seeing the
literature so it looks like journals
with sketches in it's very cool okay
this looks bad so did the father like
disappear somewhere in the house or what
I know the way to the lab is blocked is
there a way to destroy these rocks with
my giant monolith oh look I'm gonna make
some explosives 29th of March 1824 today
I am nine years old so I want to prove
that I'm a big girl I wanted to say
found in the wine cellar
daddy told me never no no down those
stairs what I wanted to do anyway I
don't like it down here it's dark it's
no funny I handled it hippy bugs okay
keep that up the rats that crawl around
I smell funny smells coming from daddy
to that door but I can't get in because
it's locked I think I hear talking
coming from the fence in the floor
sounds like people are crying down there
I wonder what the air so is that about
well yep that's opium Oh
yeah I mean just say no to drugs alright
so um that's an icky bug so icky
oh I hate the icky bugs I wonder how old
Emma's supposed to be now she has a
rather masculine hand holding that
lantern just say Emma aha nitric acid
that sounds about right looks like we're
gonna make the nitric nitro glycerine
[Music]
tinderbox thank you okay 21st of June
1829 I have discovered that mixing
certain chemicals together yields a wide
range of results for example mixing
purified opium with ethanol produced
produces the healing compound laudanum
conversely mixing two relatively
harmless subsets hands together could
produce volatile and even explosive
mixtures care must be taken in these
instances as carelessly mixing compounds
could result in serious injury I must
remember to use the chemical mixing
container when doing this in an effort
to discourage accidental mixing and
potentially explosive chemicals I have
made sure to place such chemicals in
opposite wings of our cellar
well thank you Dad oh god don't let me
do anything dad gah
baby if I mix two chemicals together I
can create an explosive compound to
clear those rocks that sounds like a
great idea I'm gonna do it I'm on a
record ah where how why
is he really there was that do the Figge
thank you one house that was a real one
he's really there I ran by I'm okay I'm
okay
oh no wait I'm all out of time I'm
actually all that time for once so I'm
gonna actually do this so thank you all
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next part but I